[Music]
hello youtube chess Louis and my friends
this is grunge in here welcome to the
third episode of my advanced chess and
game tutorials in this episode I'm going
to demonstrate one of the important
concept of end game known as
breakthrough what is breakthrough
well breakthrough can be described as
sacrificing one or more points in order
to create pass porn and win the game I
have carefully selected two complex
examples for you which covers the oral
aspect of this fundamental and the first
position you can easily see that it's a
pretty much blocked porn except there is
a major difference that white King is
quite active compared to the black and
it seems like in near future
white King is going to munch all of this
black porn but it's black to moon and
amazingly enough black and windus
endgame with the help of breakthrough
before I show it to you I want you to
pause this video and figure out how
black can achieve it
okay then are you ready congratulations
if you find this first critical move f4
so as you can see I have highlighted by
the arrows White has three different
choices
neither of them help him to save this
game let's see each bite on the first
move I want to consider is King captures
defy well after that black response is
very obvious black is going to play the
move f3 so if allowed then black will
capture on g2 and then promote the Queen
so white response is pretty much force
or it has to capture on f3 but after
that black has this amazing second pawn
sacrifice at
threatening s tree promoting the Queen
so white is obliged to capture the
second point again and now comes the
winning blow yep you guessed it it's g3
threatening queening that one again so
white is obliged to capture once again
and after this whole sequence even
though black has the only pawn left on
the board it is the first prize winner
for promoting the Queen and winning the
game let's look at the second option
what happens if you open and continue
sweet and G captures f4 well I think
this is pretty much easy one has after
the MU H for black is indeed threatening
the MU s 3 s 2 in ashwin queen with
somehow white cannot prevent it so for
example the best line goes as follows
but can try to promote his spawn on F
file with the queening fi has three
epochs and here after king to b7 it is
pretty obvious that black can able to
stop the upon ruling but white King
cannot stop the h-bomb last but not
least what happens if he captures f4
well this time around pretty much same
story we are going to play the mu H for
threatening h3 and when white capture
this pawn we have this star mu g3 and it
doesn't matter whether white plays after
your F captures g3 it will clear the
path for the a pawn which will roll down
the ball with ease and stem the winning
point
okay now let's look at the second
example where we have pretty much same
scenario except white has two extra pawn
on the Kings side and once again I want
you to pause this video and find out the
winning sequence for the black now
before I start there's a funny story
behind this end game this position
actually occurred between Havas II and
Pico in Budapest 1976 where black player
had this position thinks that well white
bones are rolling down on the Kings side
I don't have much scope
I better resign and later on comes to
know that he missed the force win so in
case in your own game if you reach
similar kind of position do not give up
but look out for the breakthrough and
you never know you win in a very
critical round congratulations if you
find the first winning blow c4 and as it
turn out White has three options
let's see any of them can help him the
first obvious option I need to consider
is D capture c4 which I think it's a
pretty easy one as after the move
a four we are threatening a three so
white is obliged to capture this pawn
afterwards we create the clearance path
for the D pawn with the move b3 and
after pawn captures b3 + d3 white King
can never able to stop that pawn
the second new I want to consider is
King to g3 well after that if you
carefully look at the last example I
don't think so you have any problem to
find out this movie for threatening a
three-wide is obliged to capture this
pawn and now comes b3 threatening be
captured c2 so once again but is forced
to capture this pawn but after that the
winning blow yup you guessed it it's a
pretty easy
c3 threatening pawn captures b2 and
after pawn takes and pawn takes you know
all these scenarios white King is too
slow to handle black pass pawn probably
the most critical line is B capture
seafood which creates White's
own passport on the C file and after the
obvious response a for what can go ahead
and play the move c5 Black has two
choices among them one is right and one
is wrong kindly pause the video and find
out which one is the right choice for
you well if you choose the MU King to f6
then I'm really sorry
you turn the table and now it is white
who is winning this game and is after
the MU G Phi it doesn't matter whatever
black plays it is now white who is in
charge of the game well if you take that
pawn then C pawn will be queening and
after the obvious response King to e6
what has this little new at six
and after pawn takes and pawn takes
black King can never handle two floating
pawns at one time
so accordingly here the right choice is
a three you should not go to King up six
and after the pond race start with B
captures a 3 B captures a 3 c 6a - and
after C 7 even promoting Queen and c8
promoting Queen yes indeed both the side
manage to promote their pawn to the
Queen but it is black to move and the
good perspective for the black here is
white King is in a very bad position the
simple winning plan for the black is he
wants to take g4 with a check so the
Queen will be exchanged and later on
black and take the h5 porn and Queen his
Jeep on let's see how we can achieve
this first of all Queen check if King to
H 2 then Queen to F 2 and s I have
highlighted by the arrows black and
simply take g4 with a check so the most
critical response over here is King to
g3 afterwards we can pretty much get the
same pattern with Queen to f4 check King
to h3 Queen to f3 check King to s -
Quinn - f2 check King to h3 Queen to h4
check which force King to go away from
the g4 pawn and after King g2 Queen
captures g4 white is forced to capture
the screen and after King takes King to
f2 and King kept us at 5 after all the
fireworks black obtained a pass to G
pawn and even though white has some
breakthrough in this position in all the
variations he cannot survive from this
position that's it guys I hope you enjoy
and learn this wonderful concept of
breakthrough which enhance your endgame
skill and create a better winning
chances if you somehow stumble and this
kind of
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment and
I'll meet you in my next episode very
soon bye and take care